[Music]
Shushan had just received yet another
invitation to the opening ceremony of
the new jing shan temple his wife by a
surgeon had warned him not to attend
since she was in fact a benevolent white
snake spirit in human form their
marriage had already weathered attacks
by meddling monks but devout Buddhist
that he was sheesh and felt obligated to
make an appearance what they didn't know
was that these invitations had come from
none other than fahai the misguided monk
who had tried to separate the young
lovers almost killing she's Han in the
process the monk confronted she's yin
telling him that because he consorted
with a demon he must remain at the
monastery and cleanse his soul she's in
protested but fahai would not let him
escape at home by a show Jen was uneasy
her husband had departed so quickly that
she hadn't been able to tell him she was
pregnant with his child and now he had
been gone so long she sent something
must be wrong she made her way to the
temple and upon encountering fahai the
monk threw his prayer mat which erupted
into fire and smoke weakened from her
pregnancy by a shrewd end Esper Utley
summoned a fleet of shrimp soldiers and
crab generals to subdue them up and
waves to put out the blaze but the water
also flooded the surrounding area
drowning many innocent villagers for the
first time by a show Jen had harmed
humans and she fell out of the God's
favor with their blessing retracted
fahai attempted to trap her in his
magical alms Bowl but just when all hope
seemed lost a bright glow came from
within her belly saving her from the mad
monks magic the couple fled home
grateful to the mysterious power that
had saved them and soon after by Odin
gave birth to their son she's shooting
yet despite this joyous occasion she
Shin was uneasy he was shaken by his
wife's accidental act of destruction and
he feared the misfortune it might bring
upon their home
not a month later fahai appeared at
their doorstep he offered she sent in
almsbowl to ensure good fortune for his
newborn son still wary of the monk but
also remembering by surgeons destructive
act she Shin accepted the gift but as
soon as the bull entered their home it
flew to bash Wooten's head and trapped
her inside against the family's wishes
Fahed the bowl beneath the layfon pagoda
and when she Shan begged him to release
his wife the monk sternly replied she
will be free when the iron tree blooms
overcome with guilt shi Shan ran away to
a monastery leaving Schilling in the
care of his aunt but there was something
neither of them knew the boy was the
reincarnation of wind she seen the
wisdom God sent to the family to reward
she's hands devotion it was this power
that had protected by a Shogun at the
temple and as he grew so did his wisdom
at age 19 Schilling went to the capital
city to take the nationwide Imperial
exam and obtain the highest score in all
the Empire the Emperor himself bestowed
Stirling's prize an ornate hat decorated
with jewel encrusted flowers but though
he returned home in glory the fate of
his parents still read heavy on his mind
coaxing his father from exile schilling
took him to visit the layfon pagoda to
pay respects to his mother kneeling
before it he placed his jeweled prize on
the iron tree as an offering suddenly
the ground opened and Biogen stepped up
with her sins absolved by the tribute of
a god and a blossom on the iron tree
shilling had freed his mother and
reunited his family
both mortal and divine for more Chinese
mythology check out the story behind the
Chinese zodiac or dive into further
tales of divine disguises with this
video
you
[Music]